about eight years ago in the UK I was
outed by a mental health charity because
they asked me if they could take a photo
of me to raise money in one of their
little you know pamphlets and I said
yeah and I thought it was gonna be a
tiny you know tiny fingernail clipping
of a picture but there were huge posters
all over the UK gigantic and I looked
like a Lithuanian peasant and it said on
it one I don't know who wrote this one
and four people have mental illness one
in five people have dandruff I have both
mortified so I thought you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna write a show and I'm
gonna make that look like it's my
publicity poster so I did write a show
and I did it in mental institutions for
the first two years and I think they
liked it but I couldn't tell cuz they
were weren't always facing me and then I
made a joke I said the bipolars used to
say I laughed I cried and really if you
can make a psychotic laugh you're
halfway in a broad way what happened was
then we would have I would do my show
then we'd have a little bit of a lunch
break and we used to steal food from the
anorexics because and then we come back
we'd ever discussion fabulous
discussions I won't even go into their
questions but and o-p-s I wasn't talking
down to him because they knew I was of
the tribe okay so you know how people go
how'd you do that I was one of them so
then the show took off and I did it in
all theatres in Australia in Cape Town
and London everywhere I did this show
and the audience would ask me the same
questions and it became a kind of even
for a thousand people one guy would
stand up and he'd say you know real
butch guy I've been on antidepressants
for 20 years I've never told my wife and
she was sitting next to him and it was
like the Muppets in there like people
would be beside themselves you know
where do I go how do I get help
and sometimes it was heavy you know one
woman said I have cancer and depression
and I said well which is worse and she
said well with the cancer all I wanted
to do was live and with the depression I
just wanted to die other people were
quite funny so this became a walk in
center and on my days off I would I
would use it as a Welcome Center and I
bring in doctors and neuroscientists and
invite people off the street and have
whole army of therapists so they could
get help bully for me I you know we
needed in kind of a a have it so
organized and this is like you know
how'd they get it together their drugs
so I made this a walk in Center and then
what happened was I had a depression it
doesn't define my life seven years ago I
had a really bad one I ended up on a
kind of a chair for a few months let me
just say people think I'm just going
sideways that depression is about having
a bad hair day or and your cat left out
it isn't sad nothing to do with sadness
you it's like your old personality
slowly leaves town and you're left with
a block of cement which is you I mean
it's like being in hibernation but you
can't wake up and and so I ended up in a
chair to take a shower was unimaginable
I didn't tell anybody didn't tell my
friends because you know what comes with
this disease is a real sense of shame
because everybody thinks we'll look at
you you know you have everything you're
not in the township you're not being
carpet bomb so I always say you get
these abusive voices like but not one
voice about a hundred thousand voices
like if the devil had Tourette's that's
what it would sound like so I was sick I
never told any but I got a few phone
calls from a few friends saying perk up
yeah perk up cuz I never thought of that
so then I was really interested in how
the brain works because I thought well
every other organ in your body can get
sick and you get sympathy except your
brain so I thought let's learn about the
brain I saw I gave up my career kiss
that one bye-bye and decided I would do
research as to how this baby works cuz
we know so much about technology but we
know nothing about the mind you know
it's running us we're not running in so
I decided okay let's do research and
find out how I can maybe control my
chemicals you know how I could cool the
engine so I researched it in mindfulness
based cognitive therapy had the best
results otherwise I would have gone in a
workshop for how to hug your inner elf
you know I'm not into the fluffy stuff
so because of the empirical evidence I
studied so I found the founder one of
the founders he was a professor at
Oxford so I you know I I have the drive
of a Rottweiler so I drove to Oxford it
was at the time I was
I think I smashed into some trees on the
way when I got to him I was and I said
to him just tell me in a nutshell what
happens in the brain what happens in the
brain when you do this mindfulness
because I you know I don't want to wave
crystals he said you'd have to get into
Oxford and get your masters if you want
to know about the brain so I did and I
graduated in September and I got the bat
wings and you know the Hogwart had and
and so it made my life so much easier
because of this thing called
neuroplasticity which I don't understand
why it's not shouted from rooftops that
you can change the wiring in your brain
by changing how you think basically we
used to think we were at the mercy of
our genes but you know like how you come
into the world is how you come how you
go out I mean I look the length of your
leg and the color of your eyes those you
inherit there's no question because I'll
never forgive my parents for giving me
the legs of a dachshund because I wanted
to go down that catwalk and now I come
to terms ain't gonna happen but the
genes that develop your brain they keep
changing because they're dependent on
experience so it's like they hand you a
blueprint and a deck of cards but how
you play them is up to you so you know I
can't understand why other people don't
know this information I mean it's 2014
2014 I have a girlfriend who sent me
just educated sent me to somebody to
tell me about my past life I don't know
if you know this but I was a window
cleaner in 1742 everybody else
Nefertiti I'm a window cleaner I'm
thinking it's 2014 this stuff is
available where's the public on this one
like ask me about my star sign what the
hell are you talk they know you can look
in a brain with a brain scanner and see
those neurons wire and unwire and that
corresponds to how you think
and every time they wire together you're
laying down memory but the good news is
you can unwire them and create new
habits and give yourself a more flexible
or happier life whatever that means I
mean you're the architect of your own
brain
it's known as neuroplasticity which was
so hopeful to me so I always say Gloria
Gaynor was wrong when she sang that song
I am when I am you're not you have many
possibilities so she's gonna have to
change those lyrics because what rhymes
with neuroplasticity